Please welcome to Google and Arbor Senior Vice President of marketing,
Tony and Rosa.
Yeah,
you're going away.
Thank you for the warm welcome everyone.
I mean I do know why you really are here.
We had to bring the eighteens,
our famous beanie.
So,
uh,
we're uh,
we're excited to see all of you sporting it.
I live around Ann Arbor,
so I'll be looking for those beanies,
uh,
throughout town.
So thank you again for coming.
Um,
before I kick off with the whole presentation,
I have strategically placed videos in here to make sure you all stay awake cause
it is,
you know,
that one to two o'clock witching hour after lunch.
Um,
but the first one is really to bring the life,
hopefully for many of you,
the true spirit and essence of what we're all about.
It's a recent film that we produced in partnership with Jason Momoa.
So if a few of you may know who he is,
pretty famous for different roles and lead leading parts,
he's,
uh,
been able to secure and we have been very fortunate to be become close friends
with him over the last three and a half years.
He's directed and produced a four of our last commercials and he grew up in Iowa
Kid,
uh,
you know,
and,
and the son of a single mom,
um,
and raised by his grandfathers who were farmers and carpenters as well.
So I'm gonna kick things off with the film that we did in partnership with Jason
that really speaks to the power of building a legacy for that next generation.
Yeah.
Ever since I was a little boy,
always wanted to be a father,
but never in my life did I ever think that would be an actor.
I was raised in small town America,
surrounded by hard work,
cornfields and pigs.
My uncles and grandfather were the hunters and builders of the Midwest.
I was raised by a strong single mother.
My Mom's an artist in every way.
She's a painter and a photographer.
So water,
always searching,
always seeing,
I guess you could say my mom came your eyes.
My mom introduced me to skateboarding and rock climbing.
I have solutely love her for that.
Just keyboarding.
It gave birth to a style
for me.
It wasn't just the skating,
it was the music.
It was the crew.
The underground
architecture was forever changed.
You wouldn't believe how much fun you could have on a curb
and climbing.
It made me face my fears and my doubts or the impossibles problem.
Solve through movement.
I'm going to trust my hands,
find my feet,
but on balance can I found my passion.
I want her to see the world climbing
a crazy road at the wild,
wanting to get out,
explored all
camping fires,
playing music,
tone stories,
living in the dirt,
in crackers and sardines
cause a dirt bag.
It's not a Carolyn world.
Back to my life.
I put it on my back.
Free to wander everywhere from Tibet,
France,
Italy,
Japan,
everywhere you were,
my travels made me a student of life.
Somehow that path led me to a crossroads and at the end of that road acting
cornered,
she seduced me
for an anxious young man at finally allowed me to be anything that I wanted to
be.
The wanderlust,
gave way to direction and purpose
can be a barbarian bartender.
The savage Cole are the king of Atlantis.
19 years I've been doing this.
I'm an actor or director at right in the produce.
I found my path,
craftsmen,
my craft of storytelling,
and then it happened.
She came my muse,
the love of my life,
my partner in crime,
I felt stupid,
crazy,
madly in love with her.
My wife gave me three beautiful feral kids,
Zo bear,
Lola bear,
and the wolf
in with them.
Dreams finally came true.
I'm a father.
I found my place.
I like any father.
We want our children to see us doing what we love,
but now my passion for storytelling pulls me away for long periods of time
and that scares me.
The nomadic lifestyle that wants inspired me and now it takes me away from the
things that I love most.
The family
I'm afraid of.
What I'm going to miss last Christ.
Be able to help them teach them.
I don't want to miss those moments.
If I think about it
in five more years,
five summers,
I'm not the center of the universe.
I decided to surround my children's who I am.
Music painting.
All my art forms
spite.
Teach them to escape.
Then they can serve for snowboard,
ultimate balance,
bold and brave in any terrain.
If I teach them to climb
and they can push themselves to the limits,
gracefully move through fear and doubt
to learn respect for our natural resources.
Cause if they can admire nature's truest colors,
making,
begin to see the beauty in all things,
to be aware of those and conspicuous and overlooked details of life.
I want to give them my eyes.
They will know art,
paint,
sculpt,
don't understand light and darkness and composition.
Find their soul.
That's what the music lives.
Teach them to play because if they can play the consent,
if they can sing,
did you dance?
When you dance,
you celebrate.
It is both
these lessons.
We teach them expression itself,
and
if I build it,
I can teach them hard work,
dedication,
integrity,
moral code.
Now,
every time my children play,
they can feel it.
The pump was always with them.
Since the moment I left my mother's house to the moment that I built a home with
my wife
from the ultimate highs,
the lows,
it brought me to my knees.
There has been one constant,
something that stayed with me through all of this
on the road.
Comfort,
disguise as arm.
I see it every time that I looked down at these pants,
my battlefield
from the paint to the stitches,
every scratch laughs and cries recorded in these pants.
Every mark is a memory.
Every tear adds up to life.
I always wanted to live.
Everything I am is in these pants
and there will come a day
I'll be gone.
My children,
my grandchildren,
they will find these beat up old car in a dusty corner somewhere and they will
know
this is the canvas of my life.
Ooh,
that's a story.
I was authentically inspired by the fact that he absolutely loves and those
pants
all the time.
He's wanted to tell a story about them and,
and it,
and it morphed through the relationship we had with him and to being really a
story about the legacy he wants to leave for his kids.
The idea that he doesn't want his kids to just know him as this,
you know,
crazy actor in superhero.
He wants to teach them,
you know,
to the responsibility he wants to teach them to enjoy making and creating.
He doesn't want them to grow up in this crazy Hollywood bubble.
You know,
where they're now out of touch with reality.
And the,
and the coolest part of all was he gave us the opportunity and the platform to
tell a story that our consumer has been sending to Carhartt for over a hundred
years.
We have pants,
Bibs,
coats,
framed on our walls with letters written by the people who say often that they
had to return it to the maker because they couldn't dare to throw it away.
And usually it's because the wife forced them to get rid of it along the way as
well.
And,
and so it was awesome to have a partner in Jason Momoa who could authentically
tell this story,
which is a story that are hardworking consumers have been telling for
generations.
And being that we're a family run business,
you know,
founded by a person by the name of Hamilton Carhartt in 1889 here in Michigan.
For those of you who don't know,
we are local.
Um,
you know,
it's a pretty powerful opportunity to be a part of a company that still owned
and operated by the founding family and we still are guided by this man's
principles and his vision and his beliefs.
You know,
that that long before anybody ever really focused on the story behind the
garment,
he was telling it.
Now it's common place,
right?
Everybody wants to know the deeper story.
They want to see the whole story behind the brand.
They believe in while he was communicating and sharing this point of view when
for instance,
child labor was a big issue in the clothing industry.
He was taking a stand against it.
He was making product up to a standard for people who did blue collar trades and
work who traditionally wore rags that were stitched together and sewn by wives
or mothers.
He said there's gotta be a better garment.
There has to be a better way to make it.
These people should have hard rugged clothing that works for the job.
So long before we had this cool athleisure trend where everybody's running
around and you know Nike or under Armour or Lulu lemon or any other brand,
he was making purpose built product for folks that most people have ignored for
decades.
He cared when others didn't.
And these are still the values that we live by today.
A lot of these values people are like,
well it sounds like a millennial mindset study that somebody had to come up
with.
Right.
And I just laugh about it because I'm always like,
whenever I'm in those meetings I'm like cause I'm an actor.
I don't know if there are any extras in here.
Probably most folks are blaming.
Oh phew.
Thank you.
It's good to see a few excerpts cause we're the forgotten generation.
Right?
Or the skipped over one.
You know,
you've got the big boomers and the big millennials.
Um,
but uh,
I always didn't like,
I'm kind of like mad.
Like they are like,
well,
you know,
millennials,
they love authentic brands.
I'm like,
did exercise where we like all about fake ones?
Like why is this so like,
why is it such a big insight?
I don't get it.
But this is our founder,
Hamilton Carhartt,
you know,
and,
and we still see it now today.
I mean,
these are pictures people send to us.
I have had the great pleasure to learn and work with really smart people at big
brands in,
a lot of people really want to talk about all the time on the news.
I didn't get things like this.
Never hardly.
I mean never.
I can guarantee it.
And when their sneakers wore out or their base layer started get stinky,
like everybody knows that polyester stuff can do right.
They didn't mail it back to us.
I'm the other,
unless they wanted to replace me,
you know?
And that's what we have here,
which is incredible.
You know,
and building off of what you just saw,
you know,
for Jason Momoa,
I mean this is one of the,
one of the letters I always like to bring this one out because those overalls,
I mean this is one stingy farmer,
but if you,
any of you ever grew up in a farming family,
you recognize the value of money and their ability to make something last in the
f and the simple.
If you can't read the fine print.
The simple story here is these bibs outlived his wife who's mended them for
years.
They outlived his neighbor who decided to start bending them for him.
So he finally was like,
well,
I guess I've got to send them back and get some new ones finally,
you know?
But it's,
it's just that incredible relationship that happens with people and the product
that they were because of all the things they do in it.
And this has guided us on a mission that,
that really,
it's still a continuation of our,
our,
our founder Hamilton with a mark filleted who's the,
the fourth generation family member.
And CEO,
I'm still today.
Um,
and that is we exist to create and build and during products to serve and
protect hardworking people.
Now probably a few people that have like Simon Sinek readers or viewers or
protagonists antagonists,
I'm sure somewhere along the line.
Um,
but if you think about it,
you know,
it is,
it is rooted in a simple why for cart that was started with Hamilton,
which is the belief and hard work.
Hampton Carhartt had a quote and I have to read it from my,
my notes here.
Work is the thing,
good earnest,
honest,
hard work in the right direction.
Everlastingly persistently,
continuously work.
Making good is merely a matter of exerting sufficient energy.
Certainly the pros of the day,
we're a little different than what we have today,
but the simple fact is this,
he appreciated hard work and that's what we still do today.
And it doesn't have to be in the form of somebody swinging a giant kick acts or
sludge hammer for us to appreciate it as well.
We appreciate the hard work of a Jason Mamoa and the lifestyle he leads.
And that's who we invite into this brand for the values we stand for.
So I often hear how this brand is being embraced by folks who typically wouldn't
be seen wearing it over the last five or six years.
That's great.
That's really good.
But we're not changing our values and we're not changing who we are all about,
but we're certainly willing to open up the umbrella as we share the story of
what car it stands for now.
Now why,
why,
why has all this happened?
I mean,
some folks have asked over the last few years,
you know,
you start to see cart more and more.
Well,
some of it is we have great partners like downtown home and garden who sold a
Beautiful Dog Chore Coat Down there that's probably being worn.
You know,
it's nice to have partners,
you know,
because your retailers are a big part of this story.
Um,
when I had the opportunity to come back home,
I grew up in the Midwest.
I grew up in Ohio,
two hours away,
a big fan of the lions,
the Tigers and the Redwings.
And uh,
you know,
my grandfather's were blue collar.
They worked in a industry machine shops.
They wore bibs,
they had the metal lunch pails.
I'll never forget that my parents were there if the first generation in their
family to actually get a college degree.
And like most families of the day they wanted to teaching because that was
really the profession that they knew to pursue.
Um,
afterwards.
And I grew up with this,
I did construction jobs.
And so the opportunity to be a part of a brand like this was amazing.
But first,
the first thing we did was we were like,
we have to spend time with our consumer.
Who are these people?
What makes them special?
Because I went from having an opportunity to sell something that more people to
want to fight about outside of politics,
but I'm not touching that now.
Yeah.
And that is your favorite sports team,
right?
Living in Ann Arbor.
There's a lot of conversation around that at the college level,
right?
If you're in Europe,
try arguing over your favorite football club or soccer club.
As you may know,
right?
There are families that are divided and never talked to each other again because
of these feuds,
right?
That's a passion for work.
That's a four letter word that most people are happy to forget about the moment
they're done with it,
right?
So it's hard to market and inspire through that unless you really understand why
they do it,
you know?
And that's what we found was,
wow,
they have stories to tell.
They have a lot of stories to tell.
Really interesting ones.
Um,
and what we started to learn more and more is they believe in this notion that
by working you earn the ability to build a better life.
They believe that making something with your hands is far greater than sitting
in a room like I'm sitting in today.
Because what I get to say I made today was a really neat keynote presentation
that hopefully kept you awake for an hour,
right?
So that's what I teach.
That's what I'll tell my kids today.
When do we,
you know,
when I see you this evening,
what did you do today,
dad?
Well,
that's what I did today.
What they value is the ability to say at the end of their day they made
something or they made many things or they built a building and that building
will forever be something they can identify with.
And we heard that over and over again.
They like to make beer.
Thank God they do.
I love craft beer and I love being in Michigan,
you know?
But that's somebody who's a maker,
And we appreciate those folks,
you know?
And we recognize something early on too.
They said something that I immediately just kind of jumped out of my seat when I
heard it.
They think with their hands.
So in a company like Google,
it's interesting to share that perspective,
right?
Because some of the brightest minds on the planet all work at Google.
I hear about it from my friends.
I went to college in New York City investment banks were scooping up all the
mines.
Then now my buddy who's a partner at BFA says,
yeah,
Google takes all the best ones now,
you know,
and it's true.
But imagine though,
how good are your hands?
Mine aren't that good.
My hands can't really make very much.
They have not a tight,
you know,
they're pretty good at that.
My wife will remind you all the jobs that I tried to take on at home and how
poorly I do with those.
And then I give up and I hire somebody actually knows how to think with their
hands,
but it's an appreciation for that fact,
you know?
And that's a powerful appreciation,
And,
and we spend a lot of time with them.
We have a team right now who's been on the road,
God bless them for over 25 days,
shooting and capturing film and photography and story after story that we're
going to bring to life this fall and holiday.
They were just in the upper peninsula with outside magazine because what we
found is if you're a brand that actually tells really interesting stories,
you don't have to pay to tell them.
That was the whole Jason Momoa film.
We're over 70 million impressions and growing and that eight and a half minute
film,
which blew away all the rules.
But let me tell you,
he was not going to change it.
You can negotiate with cal Drago all you one we did right?
And,
and the view view rate is crazy.
Full view rate is crazy.
And you guys I know can run all the stats on Youtube,
but we ran it across all platforms too.
But you would see it's breaking rules when you have an interesting real
meaningful story,
people want to cover it,
editors want to write about it.
So we're up there with outside magazine in the Upp telling stories about some of
the,
the Ski Lodge in a ski,
um,
mountains up in that,
what is it?
The Horn of the EOP.
Pretty amazing.
You know when you can do that.
But it's how you break through because we don't have a Ford Motor Company budget
when it comes to advertising,
right?
So our goal is we need to tell stories that are actually interesting and
inspiring.
Not that they don't,
but we really have to break through.
So we spend a lot of time with them.
We start to understand their personas and we've understood one thing loud and
clear.
You know that the car isn't just an outdoor outerwear brand that you wear when
it's cold.
It epitomizes an outdoor orientation towards life.
That's your route.
They don't just go outside.
We don't just go outside when it's cold out with Carhartt,
we go sound all year long as not just for men,
contrary to popular belief,
but we have a long way to go cause we have 100 and some years being for men.
Even though through the years we outfitted Rosie the riveter,
Lo and behold,
um,
and we've done things with women.
Um,
historically we've had a women's line now for about,
I've got a few folks here from work 10 years,
Lindy,
2007,
so 10 years,
10 years.
And we're going to be celebrating women in a slightly bigger way this year.
We've got a few interesting stories we want to tell and we're going to bring
those to life because we always hear after every video or commercial we run or
piece of a advertising,
you know,
from a lot of women who say,
Hey,
I'm a welder.
Why won't you tell my story?
You know,
I work just as hard.
I do a better job.
And we're like,
we're not here to say you don't.
Our problem is first and foremost with women's product,
um,
it's not readily available outside of a few destinations online in a few stores
and brick and mortar.
So thank God for Google because you can help them find us now.
You know?
And that's one of the big opportunities,
you know,
a lot of us,
a lot of people keep saying to,
what are you doing around the millennial millennium?
Millennials?
Like,
Hey,
what are we doing?
We're just being who we are and we're celebrating craft and making and doing,
which just happens to coincide with what that mindset cares about.
You know?
And that's,
that's what we're doing.
But we're being who we are.
We're not trying to be a different company,
you know,
by any stretch.
We also have a fantastically growing opportunity with the Hispanic consumer and
they're growing presence in America.
And how that's changing the face of hard work.
We're not here to be exclusive hard work.
It's hard work.
And that's what we're for no matter what the rules of engagement are.
And,
and that's something that we are spending more and more time,
better understanding and building upon as well.
But we also know it can't be just about work all the time.
If there's one thing that we like to joke about,
his beer barbecues,
beef and buddies,
the four B's,
the post work activities and,
and really capturing that in their lives,
right?
So,
so we spend a lot of time and we've got personas,
you know,
we can sit down with your team,
but I know your team has them.
You know,
we have four personas that we really focus on and build around.
And those are the four we think about all the time,
you know.
So again,
because like our,
our founder,
we believe in the legacy of hard work.
And,
and really,
you know,
we're embracing this to get people to recognize that we're not just for the
person who swings the sledge hammer.
So all of you are going to have a nice 18 you know,
but the idea here is you shouldn't feel,
oh,
I'm not really like I'm not,
I'm not the car guy or girl.
Well you can be,
it depends on your mindset quite honestly.
It really does.
You know?
And,
and that's what we're shifting a little bit,
you know,
not just that brand that makes work where it's the brand that stands for hard
work and hard working people.
Right.
Little shift,
not a big one,
you know?
And,
and then how do you make work interesting and cool and fun?
We got to really interesting places,
rugged corners of the earth.
We call them where the folks rely on card to get the job done and sometimes
survive.
It makes work a little more heroic,
more interesting.
But we also spend a lot of time with them,
camping,
fishing and hiking and hunting because we know that that is an absolute passion
place for them throughout the year.
But when we think about these activities,
like hunting for instance,
it's not about,
you know,
a lot of people,
it's like the trophy on the wall.
That's not what we hear all the time.
It's not a,
not it at all.
It's the time you get to spend with family and friends and the traditions that
are created.
And that's what makes it so meaningful.
And that's what makes it exciting for folks.
And,
and who really understand that.
Again,
it's not about the trophy,
it's about the experience.
And again,
and there's another buzzword where the experience economy,
right?
And everyone's spending money on the experiences.
You know,
you see all of these,
it's like Ding,
Ding,
Ding.
You know,
business buzzword Bingo.
You know.
But in the end,
we're experienced based brand because our product is purpose built for people
who do things.
They don't sit on couches and watch the discovery channel to dream about a
lifestyle.
They'd live that lifestyle.
And I guess the goal is how can we inspire others to do the same?
You may be a weekend warrior now,
great pick up,
pick up a hobby,
but a couple of craft that would be success for us if we're able to do that as a
brand.
All right?
And because we know too that you know,
sometimes the best meals aren't in a restaurant kid outside and enjoy it.
This is actually a guy from,
he's the chef and owner of the grains restaurant.
If you know Brandon here locally,
great guy,
great partner,
farm to table.
We love to work with them on a lot of things.
We do a lot of things locally with friends and you know that we've built up and
developed relationships with through work and gotten to know.
So how do we outwork them all?
Um,
you know,
in a simple sense
we start with you've got to have empathy for one,
one key area.
You have to remember typical household income of that core demographic,
not the broader sense,
but the core is about 55 to $60,000.
So credit card limits,
thousand maybe two.
So one of the things that we focus on,
cause I'm responsible for our direct to consumer business to um,
my gosh,
if they have a return,
they need that return credited quickly.
$150 order is lot and it matters and they value it.
You know,
they value those dollars to get them to spend $150 on Carhartt traditionally
ends up being a Christmas purchase or a birthday purchase or something else
significant,
right?
You have to empathize with that.
You have to remember that farmer we talked about in the frugality of it,
you know,
and really,
really understand them,
that if they're going to do it,
you live up to it and you'd deliver on that promise.
And if we fail,
for some reason with our product,
we always,
always take it back.
And we always make them good.
Good on that promise.
We absolutely believe in inspiring a way of life.
It's what we live for.
That's what one of the things that makes this job so awesome is because we can
do that.
And we have an owner who believes in that way of life is family's believed in it
since the founder,
you know,
and,
and we look at it through their passions and live it through their passions all
the time with emotional,
authentic,
original stories.
And people always go,
well,
why?
Well there's a part of your brain that causes people to love people.
It also causes you to love that dog and love brands.
And the best brands get that.
You can't explain that though with a spreadsheet sometimes in meetings outside
of some studies that talk about people and their connectedness or their love of
brand.
So you can do that.
And what they found through the years is that that has the closest correlation
to revenue over loyalty.
Your love of a brand has a higher correlation to revenue than loyalty.
And it means something and it's important in this day and age.
And so that's one of the reasons we really focus on that because we also want to
be top of mind.
How do I just roommate top line,
because I've seen all your stats.
It drives me nuts.
Most Google searches don't start with a brand in mind.
It's like,
Oh God,
so they just do coats.
That's horrible.
You know,
I want you to do car coats.
cause if you look at coats you might see a better deal from somebody else.
Right?
But that happens.
So you have to be emotionally engaged and connected and we have to broaden our
reach in order to do that.
Okay.
So build trust and loyalty.
These are three newest consumer profiles we've identified today.
Chris,
who's that millennial mindset working in,
working in the trades,
typically learning their way through Samantha,
more of an expert on the female end of the spectrum.
And then David Garcia,
Hispanic profile,
English speaking,
second generation,
you know,
living basically an all American style of life,
but certainly very,
very tied to the traditions of where he and his family come from.
You know?
So those are the three new ones.
And we have a mic consumer that we identify with and he's the traditional over
45 guy that most people recognize with the card.
All right.
So along the way,
we're not saying we're ignoring him by any stretch.
He's the most loyal spending the most right now because he has the most money to
spend.
Um,
well what we are saying is as we shift our vow,
our shift,
our messaging in reach and target,
we're going after these folks.
First and foremost,
Mike continues to overhear it and he's not seeing anything with this brand that
would freak them out and tell him,
wait a minute,
what happened to my car?
Um,
you guys really help us with this.
We have a saying,
you know,
are we doing everything possible to make it easy for hardworking people to
choose Carhartt?
So that's what guides our actions.
That's what guides our effort.
And our goal is to do that all year long.
We have a big challenge though.
We do not sell our product in the number one places.
They like to shop outside of one,
which is a competitor of yours,
Amazon slightly.
That is the only place we are,
that is a dominant desk destination for shoppers today.
And they're just building apparel as a destination choice for them.
Right?
We're not Walmart,
we're not in target.
We're not in Coles.
We're not JC Penney and Sears.
Thank God
nobody.
You know,
you can delete that later.
Um,
but we're not in these places where the bulk of all clothing is bought.
All the studies tell us that those are purposeful choices that we make,
not because we want to make our life difficult for the consumer,
but because of the way we believe in running our business and running the brand
and they just don't match up with our beliefs today.
Right?
So what that means is we're not always easy and accessible and then a
convenience driven world.
I was just saying this the other day,
um,
and I,
and I mentioned it at lunch,
we are in an age of brands because retailers going through an incredibly
difficult time.
For those of you working with retailers right now,
they are really challenged.
If you have not invested in the web,
it's too late and you probably don't have the capital to do it because it's all
sunk.
A bunch of stores that are underperforming.
And so you have to figure out how to get out of those stores.
And,
and,
and we've had meetings with some retailers who will go unnamed who are very
longstanding partners of ours who had been like,
you know,
this Internet thing.
I just still can't figure it out.
And literally that's what's come out of their mouth.
And you just look at it and you go,
Oh God,
you know,
like,
I don't know what to tell you other than you are not on the radar of the next
generation.
You may have your current but the next generation doesn't even know you exist.
Right.
Cause you're not a part of that journey.
And unfortunately it's too many retailers and they don't even know where to
start.
So if there's ever an opportunity for business for you guys,
it's figuring that out for them because they can't do it.
They flat out can't and we need them to buy and large.
Um,
because ultimately it will define how many square feet per person we have from a
retail perspective and whether or not the 20,
I think we're at like 20 and the,
and the UK.
And Europe is at like five,
so we forex every other country when it comes to how much retail we have
dedicated per person.
We've over retailed this country.
So it's going to decline.
But we would still like there to be some retail stores around please.
Um,
70% of people still say they'd rather buy clothing in a store because they'd
like to try it on.
They like to feel it.
They'd like to make sure that fit is what it says it is.
They don't want to deal with the hassle of returns.
Number one complaint still with our consumer.
What a nightmare.
And what's odd is rather than return it to us,
a lot of them say they'd rather just sell it on craigslist or on Ebay.
And I'm like,
you still have to ship it.
You know?
But that's what they say.
I don't know why.
So,
you know,
that's our,
that's one of our key areas of focus.
Um,
because we really believe in this idea that we're out of the disruptor phase of
marketing.
It is not about disrupting,
it's about enabling.
How are we enabling and empowering that path to purchase.
And again,
you guys play a big,
big part in this and that's,
that's the focus all the time as a team over and over again.
How do we break down,
cause it's a challenge inside our walls.
We had too many silos every single day within marketing and other worlds.
It's like guys,
this is not about us.
This is about them and we are in service to their journey.
We're in service to their ability to choose us because that's what's going to
keep the lights on and keep the legacy alive for the fifth generation of
Carhartt that's already in the business learning the business today.
We have all three kids working in the business right now,
which is awesome
and we're always measuring and we're always learning and we're always looking at
it again and again and say how can we get better?
What else can we get out out of their way?
What else is getting in the blocking them from making the right choice?
Right?
And you guys again provide a lot of great metrics on this traditional I've
always enjoyed and I'm just going to make one plug.
I haven't seen the,
like the Q four results are those in yet because I always love like the Q four
graph that shows search and how we did and what's going on because that gives us
an idea life.
Beautiful.
Um,
so we're always measuring.
So another video to kind of wrap this all up for you guys here.
And then I've got just a quick breakdown of how we look at things from a media
perspective as well.
[inaudible]
look overview.
So just to let you know where we're up to,
we're going to continue a story.
We started last year.
We're just celebrating the future through our heritage and our founder and his
guiding principles were at a long time we've been making new products,
introducing a lot more products.
We're overcoming the stigma that used to be that the new product from cart was a
new color.
So know we're launching a lot of new products because we really want to be your
round relevant and we're committed and dedicated to fuck to making that happen.
Oh.
So that folks just don't reach for their car heart when the mercury drops.
We want to be that year round brand and I'm not,
I'm just showing this to say,
and we are dedicated from a brand calendar.
We are constantly executing content,
storytelling and messaging to be relevant and top of mind as often as our dollar
will allow us to be across multiple channels.
All right?
And we break it down in three ways.
Um,
and we do this because my paid bucket is not big enough to do it any other way,
right?
My owned and earned are just as important to us as our paid.
And,
and so that's how we think about things because I cannot beat the competition by
just outspending the competition.
And really the team is really focused on this.
So when they owned bucket,
just a few examples.
Our website,
we look at this as the front door to the brand and we have a lot of work to do
still,
but we've made tremendous progress over the last three years.
You know,
I see the dog gone Google speed analysis you send to us.
I know we're meeting with our agencies.
We want to make it faster for mobile.
We know for three G it's too slow.
So we get it.
You know,
I just got it.
I like my CIO though,
says we just need an APP.
I'm like,
okay,
we need an APP.
But what about for all the other people who don't want to have the APP?
Right.
So we're working on it.
Um,
we launched a store,
a flagship store in Detroit.
Everyone said,
what on earth were you doing putting a store in midtown?
We'd look kind of smart now.
Thank God.
Um,
I mean it's doing really,
really well and we have a nice billboard there on the side and it does a great
job of letting people know that we're there in Detroit and a lot of pride and
it's been in a lot of videos really commemorating their pride and return of
Detroit.
And that's the interior as you walk in,
you know,
we view that as own though every person who walks in the retail stores we own
and operate is having a Carhartt experience.
We directly deliver.
That is a powerful owned opportunity just from a marketing standpoint.
Little on a selling standpoint.
If we leave them with a great experience with the brand and the types of people
that work there,
that's a win.
Now granted,
we'd like them to buy stuff too cause we need to pay the bills,
but every person who walks through gets a better sense of who we are.
They recognize that we're not just brown duct bibs and coats.
They're like,
oh my God,
we hear it all the time.
Wow,
this is heart.
We make all this stuff.
And we're like,
yeah,
we do
men's journal and,
and really what we're looking at,
I think I skipped a slide.
Yeah.
Well here I'm going to skip forward earned.
Here we go.
I'll go back and forth.
Um,
we don't want you to beer to celebrate 120 fifth with new Holland on the west
side of the state.
Men's journal said,
that's a really cool idea.
We'd like to cover it.
So we did a tour all the way to the great American beer festival in Denver and
we had a pint with consumers in every town along the way and brought their
stories to life.
And this was really as just a celebration.
Hey,
what do you do it when you celebrate,
you drink a beer,
you raise a toast.
Well that's,
that's what this was meant to do.
And it led to tons and tons of earned media and impressions and storytelling.
I hear there's,
I heard there was a sneaker head in here,
maybe one or two.
We did this in collaboration with m and M and brand Jordan.
Why did we do it?
Well,
first and foremost,
we did it to raise funds for the versus project that's run by Michigan state in
inner city Detroit hundred percent dedicated to one thing,
which is what m and m talked about that he cares the most about,
which is the reason he's where he is today is because he actually went back to
school and he learned how to read and write.
If he couldn't read and write,
he wouldn't be who he is today.
And unfortunately the illiteracy rate in Detroit is astoundingly high.
And if you can't read and write,
you can't even get it.
You can't get a traits job,
which is what we're focused on.
Two.
So this we raised a crazy amount of money auctioning off 10 pairs and it's still
one of the most sought after sneakers right now.
Uh,
the Jordan brand,
we stay in touch with them,
they're getting calls all the time from famous people who are dying to get them
and,
and it just continues to live on.
But the purpose was first and foremost to do a good thing in our backyard and it
allowed us to do it and crazy amounts of coverage.
Another backyard partner Chevy trucks came to us and said,
you know,
I don't,
we were like,
we don't know why we didn't do this like 25 years ago,
but he'd make a lot of sense for us to do a truck with you guys and make it the
ultimate work truck.
So this was a showcase truck.
It was at the auto show in Detroit.
It was in la,
it was at a couple of other big shows.
And it's been a really,
really,
really well received concept and idea.
So we're going to continue to talk with one another and see if that we can
actually figure out if this makes sense for a production run as well to make the
ultimate work truck.
You guys saw this on the earned side.
Again,
you know,
collaborations and partnerships to tell meaningful stories.
We're also very active in movies.
We love it.
This jacket,
the year this movie came out,
sold it out so that in the US and in Europe,
swear to God,
that jacket,
that jacket hadn't moved beyond its normal trajectory for decades.
This movie comes out,
Bam.
It's unbelievable.
Just won an Oscar for Manchester by the sea again wearing our jacket throughout
that film.
And then we have a superhero now,
our first superhero.
Everyone know who this is?
Luke cage.
Do you know what happened when this show debuted on Netflix?
Guys had to laugh about this.
We haven't who you are.
It crashed Netflix.
Would this show debuted at crash Netflix?
We're super excited about the next season.
I guess they're pulling them all together and some other cast,
I forget what it's,
my son would tell me what it is.
Um,
but I,
but he's going to be wearing our new coat,
which is called full swing and he continues to wear the car print.
And then on the paid front,
I had to put a plug in for you guys.
This is from this morning.
Thankfully Emily,
we're at the top.
That was good.
And I did not click on the ad.
I never do and it please don't.
Um,
I know you guys want us to,
but I don't,
I always tell people at work,
don't click on the top one,
go down to the one that's free.
Sorry.
We have enough people that are clicking on the top one.
It's working really well.
Um,
but this is,
this is such a discovery mode and for us,
this is one of those signals that we love to look at to see how people are
reacting to our work.
We see that people will start searching us more aggressively if our work is
really resonating.
And let me tell you,
I've got a lot of right brain.
I've got just enough left brain to survive.
But there are a lot of left brainers who got,
why don't I see numbers when we do stuff and go,
well what did it do?
And I love it when you guys can give us that kind of information like Oh my God,
look at all the search people put this happened and like within a week or so
it's powerful.
So thank you.
Um,
retail,
I talked about where we are.
This is where we are for examples.
Field and stream is a Dick's sporting goods concept in the outdoor industry.
You know our focus,
I look at this as paid and,
and the reason I do is see all that beautiful imagery and this is first and
main.
This is right when you walk in their store.
That's a billboard at the point of decision.
So I look at those as one of the most valuable spins we can make because I'm
putting front and center at that point of decision,
that zero moment of truth,
I think you guys coined a while ago,
you know this is boot barn.
Have you ever heard of a boot barn?
Anyone?
Oh my God,
somebody has.
But they are now publicly traded and they're chasing the western fashion trend
all over the country as well out of southern California.
Believe it or not,
not Texas.
Um,
and they are growing rapidly.
tractor supply and window,
treachery supply.
Yeah,
there we go.
So before I worked at card,
I thought tractor supply was,
we're tractor supplies were sold I think.
And they still have to overcome that name and they are an invaluable partner.
Great partner.
12 or 1500 doors,
I think they're up to now,
you know,
and,
and we're bringing our brand to life with them in new ways,
which is awesome.
Orchard supply hardware store in the west coast owned by Lowe's.
They are beautiful,
I think of you'd compare them to downtown,
home and garden if you recognize that that local retailer here as well.
And this is just an example of how crazy it can be with our mom and pops.
And this is why they're important to us.
This is a Hartville hardware.
It's in central Ohio.
We have somewhere in the neighborhood of like 10,000 square feet,
which is bigger than some of our retail stores.
We do millions of dollars to this one hardware store,
we really need them to figure out the internet,
you know,
again,
if that's how important it can be for us as we think about this.
And then the trips to those stores have led to this chain in Europe.
So in Ireland there's a hardware chain called woodies and we are scaling shops
all over Ireland,
um,
with,
uh,
with this hardware chain where our brand is,
is really new in the work ware space.
So that is
Carhartt.
So thank you for staying through it all.
Yeah,
thank you.
That was a,
that was awesome.
Um,
I know
being in,
in Michigan and,
uh,
personally living just outside of Detroit,
carhartts been one of those brands that really in the last like call it like
five to six years has kind of come into the,
uh,
the,
the millennials like cased,
which is kind of a benefit.
But to hear you talk about the authenticity that,
you know,
it's like you're not necessarily trying to do that.
It just works out because you're authentic without having to try.
Usually you're usually,
you're only authentic when you're not trying.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
no,
it's,
uh,
we have an amazing story to tell him.
We just need you to tell it quite honestly.
And that's,
that's,
that's what we're all focused on.
Yeah.
And so,
and,
and you touched on this a little bit,
but the decision to put the,
the store in midtown Detroit,
can you tell me a little bit about,
it sounds like maybe there was a,
there's a backstory of some debate.
There was definitely a debate.
I mean,
you've got a lot in Detroit as proud Detroit is in the office.
Okay.
People have been there for longer than I.
Yeah.
And,
and Jamie Miller who runs our retail division,
you know,
has been with us now for I think five years and he's been with great retail
brands throughout his career.
You know,
he found this space and he really had the vision for it.
And,
uh,
you know,
he championed it inside the halls because midtown w what was it,
three plus years ago when we signed the lease,
somewhere in that neighborhood,
midtown was still kind of,
you know,
merging.
And now,
I mean,
we're seeing more and more retail brands pop up all around us.
Yeah.
So it's been exciting.
We couldn't believe on people really turned out for it too.
It's doing really well.
Yeah.
Far exceeding.
No,
that's great.
Uh,
by children destroyed it this weekend.
I'm so sorry.
My bad.
Uh,
nope.
Um,
so I,
I want to talk a little bit about your career path.
It's been very cool.
I mean,
there's a lot of people in here that work with all different types of clients.
Um,
but I,
I personally work with a lot of retailers in,
in the apparel space.
So,
um,
can you take us through just Kinda your,
your career?
I mean,
we covered it a little bit,
but I'd love to hear about the path that led you to,
to God heart.
Uh,
sure.
I mean,
I'll,
I'll try to be brief.
It can be pretty boring really quickly.
You know,
I,
uh,
I just knew that I wanted to be a part of things that people were passionate
about.
Um,
I wanted to work in the marketing space.
I was an Econ,
poly side,
double major.
Most people in my space didn't go into marketing.
They went into investment banking or law.
And uh,
I just knew I wanted to be in a space that people really cared about.
Um,
my worst nightmare was trying to convince people to buy a brand or a product
that you really didn't care about.
And I've always used the example not to be,
you know,
not to be negative on the people who do that.
But like,
I would never want to be like the head of like a toilet paper brand,
you know,
or,
or something like that.
Like I wanted to be something I always said I wanted to be something that people
were passionate about and,
and,
and the,
and really the key insight for me was,
and still is,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm really passionate about things that are related to the life I grew up with
and I grew up very connected to sport.
And very connected to a blue collar way of life.
And,
and that's where that's really led my path.
And I had a really great person,
Alan Rosenshine,
um,
who was,
uh,
an alum of the university college I went to as an Undergrad,
basically give me that advice while I was trying to figure out what the heck I
wanted to do.
And he said,
just follow your heart,
follow your passion.
And,
uh,
that's what I've done every step of the way.
And I've had a chance to work for a sports agency representing a bull's players
when they made their second run of three.
I worked for planet Hollywood when everyone said that that was going to be the
next concept of experience.
And,
uh,
then I went to Nike and under Armour.
And,
and what I found every step of the way is a,
it's a heck of a lot of fun when you work for brands,
people care a great deal about,
you know,
and,
and that's what I have with the car.
I heard as well.
Very cool.
So a Nike under Armour going Ben to a lot,
a lot of big cities.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
obviously you're in proximity to your,
your hometown,
but yes,
you wound up in Dearborn,
in Carhart and Detroit.
Um,
how have you found,
how have you found the fair cities?
Oh,
great.
I mean really.
Yeah,
no,
it's funny yet I saw that.
So when I moved to Portland in [inaudible] 99,
Portland was not the Pearl.
And you see today,
it's unbelievable how that has changed.
It was pretty rough and rugged.
I lived off of Burnside and it was,
uh,
you know,
just a really,
really kind of,
it was turning,
but it was far from turning,
you know,
the Pearl district.
Anybody been there?
You know,
where the Pearl district is today.
It's basically taken over Portland.
Anyway,
some Portland now is the shining star example of a city reborn and a Baltimore
was doing the same thing.
And then I moved here and now Detroit.
I mean,
when I moved here,
I'll never forget buying a place in Ann Arbor and the lone person we were
getting the loan from at the bank was like,
everyone else is leaving.
Why are you moving here?
You know?
And I looked and I go,
well,
my wife's right here.
Thanks a lot buddy.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
but I mean,
it was just that time,
you know,
it was like there was a lot of like unsettled feelings and now you walk around
and there's confidence,
there's pride,
there's belief.
Um,
you know,
and,
and there should be,
yeah,
it's a great place to live in is one of the,
you know,
the best cup streak secrets.
I say if the,
if it had a mountain,
we'd be overpopulated because of the Great Lakes.
If we had a mountain to go with those great lakes,
it'd be over.
That would be over.
That's fair.
So,
so what you're saying is basically the next city you moved to,
we should start investing in because that's the pattern.
Got It.
So we are a,
we are almost out of time.
I've got one last question here.
I know there's a lot of,
uh,
folks in the audience,
that as we mentioned,
kind of like looked at your career path and it's very impressive.
If you had one piece of advice to somebody aspiring to,
to uh,
follow a similar,
similar path yourself.
Right.
Um,
well like I said at the beginning,
follow your passion because it will never be work and it hasn't.
And uh,
the number two thing really is,
you know,
find people,
whether you work for them or not,
who you can really,
really learn from and spend as much time as you can soaking up as much as you
can from those folks.
Because I've had the great,
great fortune of having some incredibly smart mentors from the companies where
I've worked,
who've taught me a ton.
And I definitely wouldn't be sitting here right now talking to you guys this way
if it weren't for them.
And those are really the two difference makers for me,
you know,
along the way.
Lastly,
I shouldn't leave her out.
My wife has played a pretty big role in this too,
so it's an incredible partner in crime and being willing to move the way we have
it.
Yeah.
It's funny how that happens.
Cool.
Yeah.
Thank you very much,
Tony.
I appreciate it.
A big round of applause.
Applause.
[inaudible].